hi guys sci-fi recapped here before we
start morning
spoilers ahead today i'm gonna explain a
2021 american supernatural and comedy
movie called ghostbusters afterlife
the movie begins with a van escapes from
a mine belonging to shandor mining while
being chased by an invisible creature
long story short the van crashes but the
van's driver egon spangler manages to
run to his house and powers up an
enormous ghost trap
as the invisible creature gets closer
egon steps into a pedal to activate the
trap but it doesn't work
he then flees to the house and prepares
to fight
unfortunately the ghost gets him first
and kills him in his chair
on the other side egon's estranged
daughter callie lives with her children
trevor and phoebe the little daughter
seemed to have a lot of interest in
science
not long after the building
superintendent shows up and the family
is evicted since cali is unable to pay
the mortgage
left with no option they pack up their
stuff and move to somerville where they
stop by egon's abandoned haunted house
and decide to live there
they especially trevor are shocked when
they see the house's situation a brief
earthquake occurs and phoebe discovers a
tracking device under the chair
after that janine egon's old friend
appears at the house telling the family
that the house is worthless and his
father has a debt that must be paid that
night kelly brings her kids to a dinner
at a hamburger shop where trevor is
smitten with one of the waiters lucky
since the shop needs new employees he
offers himself to work there and gives
his cv to the girl cali learns that her
father was known as dirt farmer and was
a mysterious man because of his weird
interest in supernatural stuff
when they return home the tracker device
suddenly detects something and the
chessboard falls by itself which
surprised phoebe she rearranges the
chess pieces and goes to sleep
meanwhile trevor is searching reception
while he stops by a building and
discovers an ecto-1 a vehicle that was
used by the ghostbusters the next day
phoebe wakes up and finds out that the
white piece was moved
she then responds to the move with black
knight kelly drives trevor to work while
phoebe starts her summer school
she comes across mr gruberson who
teaches there and has a little
conversation with him
in class phoebe meets podcast who runs a
podcast and awkwardly interviews her
about her grandfather's death
while buying paint the shopkeeper
reveals to cali that egon showed
suspicious behavior and liked to buy
bizarre stuff in the shop after class
phoebe goes to mr gooberson's office
where she learns that he is a
seismologist and has been monitoring the
town's weird seismic activities that
occur from unknown locations for the
last few years he adds that the town
isn't anywhere near a tectonic plate but
the earthquake occurs on a daily basis
the girl then explores the town with
podcast where she tells him that she
doesn't believe in ghosts
surprised with the statement he brings
phoebe to the mine owned by shandor
mining that was forced to close down due
to supernatural activities happening
there causing the workers to leap down
the mine shaft to their death while
returning home podcasts ask the girl to
be his lab partner which she agrees to
meanwhile trevor tries to fix the
vehicle
that night phoebe notices that the white
piece moved again and replies with black
pawn
the ghost then rudely knocks the black
knight piece off the board while the
tracker device starts blinking again
she follows the signal which brings her
to the chair and finds an old ghost trap
the next day she brings the ghost trap
to the school and shows podcast who
examines it and catches the teacher's
attention
curious with the device mr gooberson
brings the students to his room and
shows them footage of the original
ghostbusters saving a city 20 years ago
after school they examine the trap
together and accidentally free a
monstrous ghost that flies toward the
shendor mine
phoebe also learns that her grandfather
egon was actually a ghostbuster
the teacher takes the kids back to
phoebe's house where podcast discovers
several ghost hunting stuff such as
aztec death whistle while the adults are
getting closer to each other the kids go
through more of egon stuff and find a
book about gozer the leader of the ghost
realm who is guarded by a powerful
gatekeeper and keymaster and will be a
threat to earth if it has risen up again
cali shows the teacher the map of
somerville but written and pictured in
ancient language
mr gruberson is fascinated with it and
takes the map with him on the other side
lucky invites trevor to spend the night
at the mine with her friends where he
tells about his family financial
situation and the reason he moved there
suddenly a ghost entity bursts out of
the mine and flies away toward the town
but the teenagers don't take it
seriously
phoebe takes the tracker device and
explores around the barn where she
discovers egon's underground workspace
there the tracking device keeps blinking
indicating that she is currently with
someone else who turns out to be egon's
ghost
she finds egon's old ghostbuster uniform
and attempts to fix a ghost capturing
weapon proton pack before returning to
her room
later that night she asks her mother
about egon specialist in science but she
brushes him off with resentment for
abandoning his family and changes the
topic telling her that she is going on a
date tomorrow with a teacher
the next morning phoebe shows the proton
pack to podcast they test out the weapon
which turns out to still be powerful
destroying the bottles entirely not long
after they hear a weird noise coming
from the old factory where they find a
muncher a blue blobby ghost eating
metals and pipes the muncher spots them
and attacks them with metal shards
coming from its mouth
phoebe fires the proton beam and
temporarily shackles it but it breaks
free and flees from the factory after
having the ecto-1 fixed trevor
immediately takes the car for a spin he
picks up phoebe and podcast as they
chase after the ghost podcast finds
another ghost trap device while phoebe
tells her brother that egon was a
ghostbuster they arrive at the town
where the kids find the muncher is
eating a fire hydrant they drive through
the town chasing after the muncher while
the nerd girl who sits on the car's
retractable seat starts shooting the
proton beam at the ghost
she manages to capture the muncher with
the proton beam but it doesn't give up
after a long chase and creating a mess
in the town podcast traps it inside the
remote controlled ghost trap as it tries
to escape to the mountain trevor
realizes that it was heading to the
place where he and lucky went to last
night as they are driving back the kids
are confronted and arrested by sheriff
domingo in the cell trevor explains the
event at the mountain earlier with lucky
telling them that he heard something say
gozer inside the mine he also learns
that lucky is the sheriff's daughter
phoebe requests a phone call and
contacts rey stance former member of
ghostbusters who now runs an occult
antique shop when the girl mentions egon
ray tells her that being a ghost hunter
used to be a promising job but not for a
long time
he also adds that all former
ghostbusters members have moved on and
live a happy life except him and egon
the last time they met each other egon
became too obsessed with ghosts telling
people that the world was coming to an
end her grandfather then took away all
the ghostbusters weapons with him and
ran away to somerville before domingo
makes her hang up phoebe tells him that
she is egon's granddaughter the adults
then arrive at the police station to
bail the kids out but their ghost
hunting equipment is confiscated
phoebe tells them that the group
captured a ghost but no one believes her
when they reach home phoebe and callie
argue as the mom keeps telling her that
her grandfather was not a decent guy and
doesn't want her daughter mixed up in
his business but phoebe understands the
reason behind it and respects her
grandpa on the other side something is
awakened and the wall in the mind starts
to crack
booberson goes to a supermarket to buy
an ice cream where he accidentally
discovers a moving marshmallow a few
moments later an army of marshmallows
comes to life and starts invading the
supermarket he keeps walking until he
spots the keymaster who then chases
after him he runs for his life and
manages to reach his car but the beast
follows him and attacks him the next day
the kids discuss about gozer a
soul-eating deity and flame dripping
deity of evil and then head over to the
mine to find out what is happening
furthermore they arrive at a temple with
a statue of gozer in the preserved body
of ivo shandor the owner of the mine and
a cult leader devoted to gozer
phoebe finds a list of years of various
seismic and supernatural events all over
the world written on the wall
suddenly an earthquake occurs and the
kids figure out the source of the
earthquake which is a ghostly portal
where all undead souls are trying to
reach the earth but several weapons
built by egon burst out proton beams
preventing them from proceeding further
now everyone understands that egon left
his family and friends for the greater
good
in the house kelly finds the tracker
device and follows the signal to egon's
underground workspace where she learns
that her father had been paying
attention to her all this time with
pictures of her all over the wall
unfortunately a white mist that turns
out to be the gatekeeper enters the room
and attacks her the kids return home
only to find out that cali has been
possessed by the evil spirit her eyes
turn orange and she starts threatening
them
meanwhile gooberson who is possessed by
the keymaster arrives at the mine and
deactivates the weapons allowing all the
evil souls to break free and causing a
great earthquake in the town
phoebe finds out that the farm near the
house is actually an enormous ghost trap
they then go to egon's lab and gather
all the ghost hunting equipment as well
as the ghostbusters uniforms
phoebe explains that the silos outside
the house act as a capacitor which can
power up hundreds of ghost traps at a
time
the kids run to the police station where
they release the muncher from the trap
and use it to destroy the metal bars
after that they retrieve their weapons
and are ready to beat the ghosts
themselves the 2021 ghostbusters drive
toward the mine while the gatekeeper and
then the keymaster rebuild the temple
and bring gozer back to life shandora
awakens and praises the evil ghost but
she is not interested and immediately
tears him into two pieces while the town
falls into widespread panic the kids
show up and try to capture gozer with a
remote controlled trap device but they
trap the gatekeeper instead kelly breaks
free from her possession while gozer is
temporarily weakened the kids rescue
cali and then immediately escape from
the temple they manage to retrieve the
four-wheel trap device containing the
gatekeeper and return to the house
the weakened gozer shows up and phoebe
tries to lure her into the massive ghost
trap devices
unfortunately as cali pulls the lever
and hits the pedal while lucky attacks
her with the proton pack the traps
malfunction and then the keymaster
releases the gatekeeper who then
possesses lucky gozer regains her power
and attempts to kill callie but suddenly
a group of old men show up they are the
original ghostbusters and they
simultaneously fire the proton beams
toward the evil spirit but goser
outpowers them and uncrosses the streams
phoebe tries to capture gozer on her own
the evil demon fights back but egons go
suddenly appears and helps his
granddaughter to defeat her the old and
new ghostbusters combine their power and
eventually manage to paralyze the demon
trevor fires the proton beams at the
silos and cali successfully activates
the massive traps which consume all the
evil spirits as well as goser
after that the old ghostbusters
apologize to egon for not believing him
while trevor rescues mr gooberson and
lucky out of the beast shell
kelly finally is able to hug her father
and understands the truth as egon's
ghost slowly diminishes
subscribe to watch more videos like this
turn on notifications and leave a like
to help the channel out thank you for
watching